so during the coronavirus I get the idea
that now you are saying I not that I get
the idea you've said I want to write
music that's how I'll use this time
because you are you're trapped in your
house and as you've said to me privately
you're just like me we do better being
trapped in the house it's not like we
sound like we leave a lot you and I are
letting our preferred lifestyle at the
moment so what will you do now will you
will you play the guitar every single
day and sit down at the same time will
you be organized and like at 9:00 a.m. I
get up I go into a studio somewhere I
closed the door and I'm gonna take out
my guitar I'm gonna strum on it until I
[ __ ] hit another song that I love
that's so surgical on yeah but maybe it
takes that the nature of making records
now is actually lends itself to this
because all getting done with a song
like and we haven't we haven't set this
up yet but I can't wait cuz once we get
it all once this rig is finished and I
have a place to sing vocals I'll
actually be able to record vocals or
whatever it may be and send it on the
files on to James who can like throw it
we tar parts on it who can then send it
you know so it's actually you're gonna
do it you mean you're gonna send you're
gonna you're gonna sing something in and
send it to him and let him so it's gonna
be like a like an email album like
you're gonna send it back and forth to
each other we're gonna just try to
bounce around all the files as much as
but man it's crazy that you can do that
now but it's it's kind of commonly
practiced anyway and yeah like okay this
is the vocals are done on this like
James to a guitar on here oh hey Mick
you play a bass line Oh PJ two keyboards
whatever that that's how we're gonna do
it and it's it's because a lot of us
have little rigs at home I'm the only
person have anything here like to record
music on I'm also another guy I'd like
to go to the studio and then leave it
behind I can't usually take work home
with me because I'll hyper fixate on it
and become a weirdo and are you gonna
write a song during coronavirus that
somehow is influenced by coronavirus and
being quarantined probably not probably
not I I think I think that that would be
a very strange like a very rock-and-roll
thing to do but I don't know if I'll be
able to work
that framework into a five single I
would be a bit that would be an extreme
feet
you